During COVID, policy makers tried to convince us
that distance education was a good substitute for
classroom learning, like here when Gavin Newsom
said it would be equivalent to in-person classes.
So this isn't true. COVID school closures were a
disaster and we keep getting new evidence showing
how bad it really was. This latest study found
that the more time kids spent in online school the
worse they did on standardized tests. The study
looked at State testing data for third through
eighth graders before and after the pandemic.
Pass rates for students in classrooms were 13
points higher in math and seven points higher in
English compared to kids who were fully online.
Similarly the latest scores on the National
Assessment for Educational Progress tests showed
the loss of two decades of progress in reading
and math. ACT test scores saw a similar drop,
dipping to their lowest point in three
decades in 2021. So the evidence is clear:
Closing schools was a terrible idea that
left a generation of kids falling behind.